- How soon can I use you?
- Do you have salt?
- My underwear keeps falling down.
- Two minute warning.
- Switch!
- Okay.
Oh my God they're already
using the blender.
- [Carl] So much more activity over there.
- Son of a (bleep)
(upbeat music)
- Here we go.
Okay, so right now we're
headed to Smorgasburg,
the tastiest, trendiest
weekly food festival that LA
has ever known.
But first, we gotta make
a stop in Santa Monica and
pick up chef Brittany
Cassidy in the 2017 RAV4.
(upbeat music)
Hello chef Brittany.
- Hello.
- So nice to finally meet you.
- Nice to meet you, how are you?
- I'm doing well are you excited?
- I'm so excited this
is gonna be so much fun.
- [Carl] Tell me a little
bit about Rustic Canyon.
- We are a very seasonal kitchen,
we change the menu quite
frequently almost nightly.
My mom's side of the family,
we're Mexican and American Indian.
My dad is French and Italian.
I have like an overview
of cooking background.
- Okay girl, let's get real.
What are the contestants
gonna be cooking today?
- It's gonna be a bit of a challenge.
Very delicious from the sea
it's not gonna be necessarily
something that they're
used to doing I'm sure.
- If I'm being honest here,
I don't really eat anything
from the sea because my older
sister scarred me when I was a kid.
This is the perfect opportunity
for me to test the theory
that your taste buds change with age.
- Absolutely.
- Hello Smorgasburg.
(audience cheers)
My name is Carl Monroe
and I am your humble host.
Welcome to Tasty Date Night.
(audience cheers)
Today we're here at downtown
Los Angeles to watch as two
couples put their relationship
and culinary skills to the
ultimate test in a cooking showdown.
Whoever impresses our judge
most can look forward to a
romantic date night at one
of LA's finest restaurants.
Let's bring out our first
couple, Melody and Andy.
- Hi I'm Andy from Santa Monica.
- What?
- Hi I'm Andy.
- And I'm Melody and we've been
together about five months.
- She cooks and I stand there and watch.
- He makes sure no fingers get cut up.
- Right, right, quality control.
I think Melody will do fine
and if I manage not to trip
over her or knock anything
over I think we should have a
pretty solid performance.
- And we're super competitive so.
He's like playing it
cool but we're gonna win.
- What she said.
- Help me welcome our
second couple Ari and Betsy.
(audience cheers)
- Hey I'm Betsy.
- My name's Ari.
- And we've been together
well we've been married for
ten years, we've been together for 17.
So before we had kids we used
to cook together all the time,
it was something we loved to do.
- We cook surrounded
by three chaotic boys,
we're just happy to be
here to get away from them.
- Precisely.
We're tired and insane.
- I want to win this thing
so we could have an amazing
dinner by ourselves.
That is again the only way
we have a date is we have to
win a game show.
Yeah, this is real high stakes for us.
- Yeah.
- Brittany, what do we have
in store for our teams today?
- I've decided to do something
that's very interactive
for couples so it's
gonna be a crab tostada.
- Oh, let's see if that
looks as good as it sounds.
(upbeat music)
So couples, watch carefully
because you are gonna have
to make this.
- Oh, hello.
- [Brittany] Getting that crab done first,
getting the crab clean,
that would be the most important step.
(upbeat music)
- Alright.
- [Carl] We got a complicated recipe.
This is gonna be pretty challenging.
- [Brittany] Those last
five minutes are gonna get
away from you real quick.
- I'll try to do it that fast.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Alright, without further
ado let's put 30 minutes
on the clock please and let's get tasty.
(audience cheers)
- I can't get my glove on.
- What are you working on,
this thing or this thing?
- I've got this red cabbage
situation the avocados.
- Okay, so I'll work on
this avocado cream nonsense.
Do I do both?
Or do I just do one?
- Oh my God I almost cut a finger off.
- You may want to break
those 'cause those crab legs
are not going to fit.
- Get in there crab.
- I don't know what I'm doing.
- I think you've gotta put the crab in.
- [Brittany] On the newbie
side you've got a joint effort
going with the slaw,
and then on the other side
it looks like we have a
delegation of tasks you know,
we'll see what works better.
(frantic music)
- I got a lot of aggression work out.
- I just cut this up?
- Well I guess you're
going for it, so yes.
- Cilantro.
- She julienned the apples
I did the red cabbage.
She has more skills.
- It needs to be smaller.
(groaning)
- Am I, am I doing this right?
- I'm having trouble focusing.
How does this work oh?
- No, oh here this is
what we have at home.
- Oh, look at you.
- We've got plenty of time.
- Oh crap that's yours.
- Ah shoot!
- We overcooked the crab by about
two minutes and 11 seconds.
- This is a disaster.
(laughing)
- What did you just do?
- We are not comfortable
unless everything is chaos.
(laughing)
- Wow, look at that technique.
- Alright you guys, we
are under ten minutes now.
- This crab leg is
empty, what is happening?
- I think I'm using these
things wrong but whatever.
Found some amazing scissors
that did wonders in
cutting the crab shell.
- One thing to always remember
is if you put liquids first
into the blender and then all
the ingredients it sucks it
down so you get a really quick blend.
- This is a nice blender.
- What the heck happened here?
- How do we toss stuff?
- I feel like with crab it's a lot of work
for very little meat.
- Oh my God there's like a
handful of jalapeno in here.
- How are we doing on time I wonder?
- Oh I'm sure we're fine on time.
- Yeah?
- Five minute warning.
- I take it back.
- Ah, what the heck.
- Are you sure there's not
supposed to be cilantro in here?
- No, cilantro's on top.
Oh wait, you're right.
- See, just put it back.
Throw this away.
I think we have extra cilantro,
I'm fairly sure they gave us
exactly the amount of cilantro
we're supposed to use.
I think we still got some leftover.
- Look at Ari and Betsy,
they are just like a little cartoon.
- That's really spicy.
- How do you make it less spicy?
- Put one tostada shell.
- Okay, take two.
- This is really nerve-wracking,
my heart is starting to
beat a little fast here.
- The design on the plate.
- You, sure, if you want to do it.
- It's a bit of flair.
- I don't know the video
was like super generous
with the crab.
Is that crazy, is it crazy?
- Go (imitates bottle squeezing)
What is that, that's a disaster.
(laughing)
- So here, how does this, woops.
- Oh, oh no, oh.
- Do you like the way that tastes?
Well it's too late now.
- [Carl] Audience can you
guys help me count down?
- [Audience and Carl] Five,
four, three, two, one, time.
- Hands in the air, hands in the air.
Now turn to your partner
and give them a hug,
that was so intense.
So cute.
(audience cheers)
Come on down Ari and Betsy.
- Alright.
- The only thing I'm worried about is
our attention to detail.
- Oh that's what you're worried about?
We overcooked the crab,
we sliced the cabbage too
thick and I added the lime
to the slaw without
emulsifying it in the sauce,
whatever emulsifying means.
- Looks good.
- Looks beautiful, I like
the cilantro garnish,
- Very colorful.
Let's dig in, I want to dig in.
Get in here.
- [Carl] Dip in there, okay.
- I eat with my hands.
- Here we go.
- This is our date night.
- Crab, I'm eating crab
for you Tasty Date Night.
- It's great.
- Alright.
- I like it.
- Uh-huh.
- Alright you guys, let's make
some noise for Ari and Betsy.
(audience cheers)
- That was so much fun.
- It was so much fun.
- It was amazing, it was a blast.
- It was delicious, we
made the chef go like mmm,
so and then also Carl
who doesn't like crab
was like into it.
- We've learned that your
perfectionism is important.
- Thank you.
- Hi, how are you, here you go.
- Hi.
- Wow.
- I think I contained
the missteps on my part
fairly well so I'm pretty confident.
- You're not giving
yourself enough credit.
He cooked the crab which
is a big component.
You pulled your weight.
- Alright I'm gonna break.
- Alright break it for me girl.
- The knife cuts on the
apple are really nice,
you don't want anything too
big so I'm gonna go straight
halfsies and let's just get into it.
- It's good.
- It's very delicious.
The julienne the dice on it
is really nice so you can
actually get a little
bit more in each bite.
It has a nice freshness.
- Let's make some noise
for Melody and Andy.
(audience cheers)
- We felt good about it,
we thought both dishes look really pretty.
She had some nice words.
- She didn't choke or anything so,
she complimented the
julienning multiple times,
each time referencing the apple
and not the red cabbage, so.
- So obviously two very different
approaches to this dish.
You kind of taste almost the
personalities in the dishes.
- [Carl] Yeah.
- [Brittany] The first one
had a lot more seasoning.
I liked the amount of crab.
It's a crab tostada.
Their knife cuts on their slaw was a
little difficult to eat.
So with Melody and Andy,
they were a lot calmer and
that translated in their flavors,
not as much salt and lime
but yet they had a lot of
precision in their cuts.
- But the portion was really
much less than Betsy and Ari,
you could tell that both
couples had a really good time
which really is the whole point of this.
- I have a definitive winner in my book.
(audience cheers)
- Welcome back.
Come on out here you guys.
The winner of Tasty Date
Night LA is Betsy and Ari.
(audience cheers)
- We're so happy.
- I cannot tell you how
meaningful that was to me.
- I was nervous though 'cause
both dishes looked exactly
identical to me but I forgot about taste.
That's a big thing.
- Oh yeah and it turned out to be.
- So excited to go to a
restaurant with awesome food
without children in it.
- Oh my goodness yes, we will
see you at Tasty All-Stars.
- Yeah.
- We're pretty devastated.
- You do like to win but then again,
it's really about the process
and having fun and we had fun.
- It was really fun to cook together.
- And we did learn another
recipe and definitely can
try it again at home.
- Thank you to Smorgasburg for hosting us,
thank you to my amazing audience.
This has been Tasty Date Night
brought to you by Toyota.